in five four three two one we go right
into it we have a very special guest
well first of all done special guest
Nick the [ __ ] here what's that
why do they call you the ear Nick I
don't know man take off those [ __ ]
headphones and show them because my ear
looks like a [ __ ] gyoza yeah that's
that's [ __ ] why David you want to
hear it I like it it looks like a chew
toy like a little heart if you look at
it really closely there's a little heart
shape and why don't you why don't you
today yeah introduce the very special
guest all right this is my bud Patrick
Reilly the most enthusiastic [ __ ] my
friend Pat he trains with us he's a
really funny comedian stand-up
extraordinaire Patrick Reilly turn it
around at the end you did so you gotta
give him up build up yeah it like
somebody's [ __ ] Korean mom dude I
didn't realize bangles you look like
you're full of love though yeah yeah
[ __ ] fat it's like you'll make us a
big bowl of kimchi when we come home
from dinner cool you're so stupid
Pat what's up hey what's going on thank
you for having me
oh you know just chillin you know just
kickin it hey pal you're at your
comedian right yeah hey tell some jokes
a joke funny guy you a funny guy dude
that's the most annoying [ __ ] thing
about being a comedian is people always
like tell me a joke tell me I've seen
like especially in the beginning dudes
try like girls bar and this guy was like
trying to hit on this girl and she
doesn't tell me a joke and he did and he
she didn't laugh at all of you how do
you start off a joke that way like I
don't even understand how you're gonna
make somebody laugh try right yeah I say
all works say a make ru your comic right
yeah tell me a joke bro tell me you're
funny right hey tell me a [ __ ] joke I
don't know man I don't think that's a it
all really apply you should try to me
okay so
like your parents you know my Cajun
what's up with Asian dad's you know
Asian water bottles and like I am I
right I've never I've never laughed so
hard in my life dude thanks man I'm
laughing so hard I'm not laughing at all
can you get me on some open mics or
something did you drink it dad's pissed
shut the [ __ ] up man yeah I did yeah
piss drinker bro dude I did a dad's
pissed my dad's fist we have like a
really close relationship it was like
real cool yeah one time he he took my
car out in the Miata classic we've
talked about it many times before
okay and I finished I finished up
playing some basketball and I usually
have jugs of water in my car I just have
water bottles in there and I went to go
pick up Tiffany from work mm-hmm
but I was really thirsty and I was like
man what the [ __ ] you some water
and even like as I'm telling the story
my mouth is just watering cuz I'm just
like you know you think it tastes good
no I feel like I'm [ __ ] about to drag
you right now so I look for a bottle of
water in the back
I find it I'm I'm so thirsty too I'm
[ __ ] really thirsty I take a swig out
of it and then my cheeks are full like
this and then I what I realize [ __ ]
something it is not okay this is at
night too this is that night I spit it
back in the water and the water bottle
and I'm like spitting off the car I'm
like draw dude I'm like dry heaving I'm
like it so [ __ ] gross why hold on a
sec and then I look at the bottle up to
the streetlamp and it's not why it's not
clear yeah it doesn't look like water
it's the darkest brown yellow you ever
seen your life there's dehydrated my dad
doesn't drink that much water he's a
smoker you know it's just not not that
good stuff I like that tasting it wasn't
enough that you had a like verify again
I don't know bro because think it's my
mom walking around many guzzles did you
get in probably seven dude you guys
didn't really make sure I was pissed no
it was just one and I know just I spit
it out
I was dry heaving dude and then
and I look at the bottle and it's
obviously not clear and then like tiff
gets in the car she's like hey what's up
guess what you try this she tries to
kiss me and I'm like oh please I think
she's like oh my god what happened I
told her and then she starts laughing
obviously but yeah like she was
horrified and then I go home and I tell
my dad lied texting him I'm like go if
you [ __ ] piss in my water bottles
throw it out yeah and then he has the
nerve to be like well you gotta check
the water bottle that's not a good point
if you have to check all you know check
check your glass before you drink I'm
everything with your dad on this one
dude you know what you're a [ __ ]
idiot yeah I believe I was on that
[ __ ] up yeah you deserve to dude yeah
deserved it coming the onion straight
from the source
[Laughter]
that's just so [ __ ] disgusting dude
that's not water it's actually pissed
yeah check it dude I'll be the judge of
that mine's clearest [ __ ] but very
hydrated Oh daddy that's all you think
abut I was like traumatized I was like I
was very upset I couldn't even look him
in the eye for a while and then he was
like yeah that's right was he pissing in
bottles though because that's what dude
apparently that's what Asian parents do
I talk no that's not what aging parent I
have Asian parents no you don't I've
told this story many times before and
then someone always goes oh yeah my dad
does that - was it your uncle your dad's
brother the same bloodline my dad's dad
no it was a it was this kid I used to
coach and he told me like oh yeah my dad
did that too okay I've peed in bottles
before and but I've been in like traffic
I'm driving like two hours and I'm like
I've done it maybe once or twice in a
very serious emergency yeah but your
dad's doing as if he does it all the
time like you just do it dude like just
all the time it's like he sees a
bathroom he goes now I'm good
he's like I have a fire what are you
crazy it's the bottle just piss but the
[ __ ] is that about
I don't know man we should have him on
next week I want a lot of things
he's a sketchball dude he's a number one
schedule I like your dad dude that's a
piece of [ __ ] the area Matt my dad you
met my mom though you know you know you
all stop talking about you it's kind of
its kind of your mom dating dude I'm not
taking her out like that though sorry
she's a sidepiece just like a booty
calls only oh yeah yeah she she doesn't
deserve the front lines yet
yeah she's got to work her way up you
got the crazy is you know because I do
you to Bishop we're just gonna get to
the topic right now I feel like this is
an interesting topic for people who
don't do YouTube except for you guys now
you have a solid 60 subscribers 70 i
watch your [ __ ] mouth famous row 70
subscribers what are you gonna do with
those 70 subscribers is the question
probably just make them do like a pay
for a subscription thing right off the
jump without writing something murder it
yeah I mean any good content yeah
make sure you sell them merch and then
teach them how to do makeup tutorials
thing yeah I have I have like 70 views
on one video so like I'm climbing up
there you know by the way as we speak
about this I'm actually until the editor
to put in that video of you hitting
pads17 spinning backfist bro that was
such a long time ago and I was forced to
do that I I didn't want to do I'm still
putting it up so I was supposed to go
help I was gonna hold for Heinrich
because he was supposed to be doing a
promo for him and I was holding some
pads for him and then they're like hey
do you want to do one and I said you
know no but the Heinrich was like hey do
a fool like you should do it that's all
right yeah that's what Heinrich sounded
you son of a [ __ ] she's a fool like you
should think about it a second of
[Laughter]
yeah and then I ended up doing it and
it's oh man I didn't even I forgot about
it and then you and Gilbert somehow
found it and you guys would always send
it to like any group chat that we're in
it is the funny thing I've ever seen in
my life it's so good the turnaround is
because they're trying to make you act
as if the camera isn't there and you
suddenly notice the camera was there
you're hitting pads like a [ __ ]
maniac doing 12 spinning backfist
just like that but it was Heinrich
stupid combo he's like a fool like it'll
look good on the video so you just kept
like calling for it and I was like
alright well I have to do what he tells
me to do well yeah it was a it was
probably one of the prouder moments in
my life that [ __ ] was hilarious dude one
of the fun I think she was the best cuz
Hydra didn't know what to do with his
hands in the gym you just kept doing
this like my name is Heinrich wasa mer
I'm fighting a rock firefight Academy
about this fist I was like fighting a
proving ground September 22nd yeah but
this is weird
so I don't I don't know too much about
you to be there so when every time I see
I like a upload [ __ ] but I don't really
watch a lot of other people's content
only because I just don't find it that
interesting but what do you watch on
YouTube i watch cooking videos shoutout
to Thrillist
cent foods your onsen food this is guy
named david on the stand for this
hilarious sick oh the really hot korean
guy the really hot tie guy Tim [ __ ]
love that show
lots a lot of food [ __ ] and a lot of
fighting stuff that's really about it so
work and then oh and also I watch I used
to watch a lot of Casey nice dead oh
okay what's what is it what kind of
stuff does he put out I didn't he used
to do this thing where he blogged every
[ __ ] day for like a year every
[ __ ] day and he made it as
interesting as possible so the guys
sleep schedule was so weird he would so
he did a video where he put out what he
would do and mind you he looks old as
[ __ ] even though he's relatively young
and I could tell just because you know
he works really hard
but he didn't sleep at all so he what he
did was he would wake up in the morning
like around 4:00 a.m. and mind you don't
quote me on this but this is just kind
of roughly what I remember he would what
is this buzzy noise that I [ __ ] up
something is the air conditioning on
know whose cuz I had my [ __ ] mi but
anyways he would wake up super early in
the morning after he would wake up he
would I think a jog like [ __ ] 10
miles 10 or 15 [ __ ] miles after that
he would come back start editing a video
to like noon or some [ __ ] run his other
company come back home and then he would
spend two hours with his family wake up
and do it all over again and he would do
this every day for a whole year some
damn he didn't put a single ad on his
videos and they on his videos hit like
millions of views it was [ __ ] crazy
Wow and then after a while he just goes
okay well now it's time for me to
monetize he started monetize videos he
still kept all of his views but he was
already known because he sold a TV show
to HBO before that so he was like a
filmmaker documentarian or whatever
before do you know what show was I don't
remember but the fact that he sold a TV
show I think he went to Sundance as well
too damn but the guy did a video every
[ __ ] day and I think in my personal
opinion he's the one that's that started
off this whole vlogging craves like
everybody started doing daily vlogs it
seems like everyone now is doing
vlogging oh right am i is that the most
obvious statement of the year dude my
ex-girlfriend used to vlog it was the
dumbest [ __ ] so I'd like wake up and
she'd be in the kitchen like so today
we're gonna make pancakes flip back in
raspberry oh my god babe they don't care
enough some tit
but this was spinning backfist or
something there are some spinning
backfist yeah pay the bills
dude you should post that now that you
have all these followers you know if you
don't repost that [ __ ] video shoot
you know I will I will repost it and
I'll [ __ ] cry on my bathroom
afterwards no that's embarrassing
buddies you know what that hold it well
do daily vlogging though it's weird
because I can't unwrap my head around it
right just because it's not something
that I do why don't you do it it's a lot
of work there's a lot of work to just
other people's days what if she just did
one day out of the week I could but it
requires me to work
and I don't want to do it haha so what
are these lot like what leg dude so he
would just vlog and talk about like it
just people just vlog about anything and
everything so he would do really
creative [ __ ] though
okay the way he did he would unbox [ __ ]
but he would do in a very creative way
or he would like find out to do is just
really experimental [ __ ] and people
[ __ ] enjoyed and even I started
enjoying it too so I can understand that
but this this whole craze happened where
people just want to see what you do want
a daily basis and I think what they do
is this they have it on his background
noise like they're not even watching the
video to be that engaging they just kind
of go about their own [ __ ] and they hear
something in the video and then they
watch it because I asked a few people
who watch vlogging cuz I used to try
doing weekly vlogs and they say they
just have it in the background so it's
it's a different generation like they
don't have to be completely engaged into
it but they do want to know what's going
on in your everyday life and I can't
figure out why but you know I don't know
because I don't know what to do right so
if so if let's say for example I were I
was gonna vlog today right they gonna
woody I would have to wake up hey good
morning guys I [ __ ] I said I took a [ __ ]
there's a little corn in there a little
bit of spinach but it's what it is so
it's a skill so they'll take one concept
and they'll talk about it and then
somehow has to be engaging like I would
literally have to be like so I took a
[ __ ] today and it's smeared a bit don't
you hate smeared poop all over the place
it's like 17 wipes have you ever watched
rs70 time to end it blood bleeding sucks
so when you bleed right sometimes you
have to use a band-aid you know those
flesh-colored band-aids you know what
sucks when they don't have black people
band-aids they're not the same color as
a band-aid that's racist racism is crazy
so when I was a kid this is this is what
they do though I'm a hug dude I want to
hear more about your poop stories that
band-aid thing was pretty good though
black band-aids and if they do have
black band-aids it'll probably be racist
well I saw this [ __ ] on Twitter bar
where there was this guy in the military
he was talking about they have like
black people band-aids now to match skin
color they call black people band-aids I
think these are called black people man
yeah they're called me grades they
[ __ ]
it's like the correct skin color he was
talking about how happy is and I didn't
[ __ ] know that they made band-aid
a skin color to match your skin tone I
just thought it was just this ugly
band-aid so you never hurt yourself
again so but it's supposed to match skin
tone I had no [ __ ] idea but when he
put it on I was like oh [ __ ] it is
supposed to Mexican but who's really
getting fooled by the color of band-aids
like am i putting on a bed who's putting
on a band-aid that skin like if it
matches their skin they still know it's
a [ __ ] band wait I like that you
think that the colors so I like the
motivation behind the color was that so
it would be so ugly that people are like
I will never use a knife that way again
that's what I thought the cut is fine
but to wear a band-aid forget it don't
ever hurt yourself again now you have to
walk around like a [ __ ] monster yeah
shame shame you disgusting that's what
band-aid colors are it's a matte skin
tone I had no [ __ ] clue [ __ ] I saw
this [ __ ] on Twitter and this is the
funniest thing so you know when you put
your your life out on YouTube or social
media it's kind of up for everyone to
interpret or grab at right or pick at so
like the more popular that you get you
have to be very careful about what you
do so so there's this couple called the
ACE family no idea who the [ __ ] these
people are that's not their real name is
it I don't know what their real names
are Nick cuz I just looked it up that's
pure talking before but babe legit I
mean let me just think up how much
[ __ ] views these [ __ ] I'm
the [ __ ] now yeah you stupid son of a
[ __ ] how about that dude
oh that's hurtful this is genius brain
this is why I'll never get sponsorship
so the ACE family which you would think
it would be a hardware store but they
have 16 million [ __ ] subscribers 16
16 [ __ ] million subscribers they have
like these cute little baby
they just record their everyday lives
but yo check this [ __ ] out dude they
average 5 million to 7 million views
her video and they upload every two or
three days one of the videos just like
them chilling and then walking around
just doing the same [ __ ] I did hey guys
this is my kid over here he blings you
know what's crazy about got a moisten
your eyeballs
when you put an eye drops in man I hate
it when eyedrops burn you know what also
burns sometimes when you Pete you have
an STD don't get STD guys this is a PSA
guys this is what they do and so this is
kind of crazy so I saw this [ __ ] on
Twitter where I guess that's a girl she
deemed the the the the lady in the
relationship and basically told her this
whole story about how the guy was
basically cheating on this is a very bad
this is such a weird thing you know why
because okay let me just read what this
girl wrote on the whole DM to her right
whoa so this is the her DM tour uh their
Instagram is called well I guess the
post was called perfect babies this is
good night Catherine Pease is her name
Catherine pays i'm slaughtering your
name cuz I could give a [ __ ] less about
you so I ate so this is the girl that
messaged her and let her know out of the
goodness of her heart quote-unquote hmm
hey girl the odds you'll read this are
slim to none I wanted to let you know
because you deserve to know as a mother
and just a woman last weekend Austin was
with some friends of mine in Miami he
slept with one of them and made her sign
an NDA classic movie good professional
yeah as you see he didn't [ __ ] work I
didn't think it was fair at all for this
to happen while you're at home with your
babies waiting on him I'm disappointed
I've been a fan since your little
apartment since L was even out of your
bail yet I hope to hope you see this I'm
not messing you for clout quote-unquote
or to start any drama
I just couldn't scroll past your
pictures or not say anything right so
she says this to her and then she
screams tap what she sends this and what
she sends and then she puts it on
Twitter for a public public and she says
I tried to turn a blind eye to the
situation but as a mother and wife I
couldn't you deserve to know I'm so
[ __ ] heartbroken for you and your
family I need you to see this if I were
in your position I would want someone to
tell me
but then she put it out to everybody
exactly this is the funniest love number
one I'm not will talk about the cheating
thing on another thing but the funny
thing about this girl who messaged her
she goes I wanted to do this privately
because I want you to know this and I
don't want any cloud I don't want people
to recognize me for it but then two
seconds later she posts it on Twitter
yeah right dude that's so rude snitch
dude that's what I yeah that's some
snitch [ __ ]
I think the odd part is just like I
don't know why I feel this way but it's
ain't knowing your [ __ ] business
[ __ ] right like what are you doing like
would you are you really so you could
sleep better at night and I'll be
defending the [ __ ] guy either you
know the guy is cheating or whatever the
threat is what it is but when I see this
and she did hurt her duty to let her
know but then she just sat around and
they should put it on Twitter so
everybody can see it it's like well if
if your objective wasn't for people to
see it then why the [ __ ] would you
publicly put it out on Twitter yeah that
would kind of ruin the whole thing like
if you're gonna be like if it's a
one-on-one like hey do I need to let you
know it's like you said it's it's just
some real [ __ ] that's fine but then
what's your like it's clearly for her to
seem like a good person it's actually
you are now I hate you you know what it
you know what it is [ __ ] it started off
by saying as a mother and as a wife do
like as a homie real quick man I'm
telling you as a person like yeah or
just cheating on I'm sorry but this is
what I found out don't you come in with
a as a friend and as a wife as a husband
whatever the [ __ ] that just sounds so
bad would you guys ever cheat yeah make
somebody sign NDA no yeah okay I want to
know about how that goes because in my
head cashews I guess you could raise
seem do you do it before or after I
think before it kind of kills the mood
great like that's that's the other thing
too is even if you were to do it
afterwards and it's still a crazy
Lebanese make you sign some random
[ __ ] NDA so I heard I heard Derek
Jeter gives out a gift basket why you
[ __ ] that up
I
the sign baseball what do you think of
that friend Becky it's signed by Derek
Jeter inside inside of it isn't it came
with hey Jeter this flops open just like
a little bit but they had I so I heard
this [ __ ] funny a story from this one
girl who uh so she was at a club and
Justin Timberlake was there right and
she was telling me that she actually got
hit up by Justin Timberlake in the most
oddest [ __ ] way possible so Justin
Timberlake's chilling and you kind of
see him off in the distance and she's
this huge guy come up next to him this
big-ass [ __ ] burly dude and he hands
her a cell phone she was what is this he
goes just answer when somebody calls you
[ __ ] weird dude what the [ __ ]
so it's it's a [ __ ] cell phone
she gets a call she picks it up it's
[ __ ] Justin fighting trying to look
for you apparently Justin Timberlake
mind you this is just hearsay so mister
mr. Timberlake if you hear this I don't
[ __ ] care I'm specific to be traced
it's not be true you know what I'm not
gonna bleep out the name but I heard
this is what she told me is that she
would give out burner phones to girls
that he wanted to talk to so they could
meet up or [ __ ] or whatever and this is
prior before his is just Jessica Biel
[ __ ] though it was like before they were
they were together but this is when he
was single but he would give like these
girls burner phones so they could meet
up and talk and then they would have to
sign like an NDA or some [ __ ] that they
hooked up or some [ __ ] Wow did she do it
mmm-hmm no she didn't I think she got
creeped out by the whole phone thing
yeah as you know which kind of said that
ruin the mood
well she thought she wasn't see the
matrix it didn't happen so it's great
that when you're like that level of
celebrity that dating like you do have
to play it differently because there are
girls out there that could lie or could
go for like set you up or be like this
dude [ __ ] raped me or like this I
mean it's it's possible because people
are you're a target you know what I mean
like so you'd like that's [ __ ] insane
dude burner
yeah she would give he'll give them like
these t-mobile what do you call that fit
that was called not t-mobile Sidekick
take a look dope but it's crazy like
with these couples too like these this
a-hole ace family like a lot of people
do this [ __ ] where they kind of they put
up this guy's own say something no
[ __ ] on the regs though like these
guys that are very famous I'm pretty
sure they are very sure right I feel
like in even this I guess this is
considered you know celebrity Hollywood
now I'd be surprised if somebody doesn't
cheat now straight up right so I would
be in like in conversation with people
in they go oh so how many side chicks do
you have I'm like who me I have none
I've side dudes but not but it's pretty
common though like dudes just
consistently have side chicks in like I
think specifically just because it's
almost like because everybody else does
it nobody's really gonna try to rat you
out right just because everybody else
has one so they kind of keep it really
tight knit and close like you have to be
a special type of uh like I guess I
don't say narcissist but you have to be
a special type of person who wanna have
that weight on you or you tell somebody
like hey I know you didn't know this but
your man's [ __ ] other chicks for sure
like for you to break that news to
somebody I don't know man that you have
to like really want some weird special
if you if you were being cheated on
right and let's say your world right now
is perfect everything is great
would you want somebody to tell you [ __ ]
that's true you have two kids too by the
way
make it three okay you have 17 kids the
better scenario yeah you like kind of
live in this you know what [ __ ] that's
true
would you I don't know you wouldn't know
I would I would I don't even know if I
would want to know like let's say like
every now and then I'm like you know
what but I don't know doesn't hurt me
are you telling me that Tiff's cheating
on me right now I'm telling you that she
is that is what the Mexican man
come on man Salvadorian Mexican yeah I'd
be pissed if she'd cheat on me with
another Asian dude yeah you know what's
worse when you get you done with the
dude that's way uglier than you and it's
like damn
Wow I don't think she could find any one
way uglier so wow they're good
that's I was fishing for you guys to be
like nah you're not ugly no Nick you're
beautiful Thanks yeah [ __ ] completely
normal she goes hey do you ever notice
your ears I'm like what are you talking
about she goes like cuz I don't I'm like
are you really really mean that
she goes no I don't even like look at
your ears anymore yeah I don't even look
at those things alright I say play ok
you're the only guy that cauliflower
ears made your ears look better I know
dude that's true because I had [ __ ]
really big ears yeah stick out like I
look like that's a very good in Asian
culture though yeah that's why my mom
was really pissed like if you have long
earlobes supposed to be for good luck or
some [ __ ] or [ __ ] or something stupid
yeah it's true though is it no yeah it's
not really working out for me there's a
lot there's a lot of [ __ ] weird Asian
sayings dude yeah you have you heard
something called Korean fan death the
dumbest [ __ ] thing every what is that
so there's this myth that if you leave a
fan on in your room it sucks all the air
out when you sleep and you die and you
suffocate Wow that's my mom [ __ ]
hilarious because the air conditioning
is just a huge [ __ ] fan yeah don't
die and so I remember when I was a kid
that's how I was sleeping in the middle
of the night and I left the fan on cuz
my parents didn't watch on the AC cuz
you know broke cheapest [ __ ] mm-hmm and
so I just left the fan on my dad just
hears like a fan he just comes busting
in my room Fanny shoves it out he's like
you could have died [ __ ] are you doing
useful as a fan day
and then my mom explained to me goes if
you leave ahead you die no air you know
you die look I was like that's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever heard in
my life alright yeah when you say that
now you when you leave the fan on when
you sleep and you die the next morning
just [ __ ] know that your parents are
absolutely right dude why would be dead
I still wouldn't [ __ ] say you're
[ __ ] like you can look it up on
Google right now put on Korean fan death
and something will pop up like that's
how positive it's in our culture am I
sure there were just so many [ __ ]
weird myths and fables I had to deal
with all the [ __ ] time like what was
this [ __ ] like the other thing like
don't step over somebody while they're
lying on the floor yeah my mom would be
very upset at me if I quiet I don't know
it's just rude it's rude what's the
whole how many opportunities do you have
to just step over [ __ ] that are
laying on the floor like we're walk in
the living room and my stupid dumbass
sisters will be singing laying on the
floor and then she would make us like
she'd be like hey don't step over them
walk around so there's that there's also
the whole umbrella thing don't open up
umbrella in this house what did you have
that once - yeah yeah I think that's
like that's all that's a mama like it's
an American culture - my mom would
always tell me how to jump if I want to
be taller didn't really work out yeah
yeah she'd always tell me like you need
a jump fish makes you smarter she used
to say that like well fish oils supposed
to be good now that's not a thing do
that something all right
what are you like a CSMA PLT yeah what
are you again yes CD ears do you no
matter the letters don't matter hijk
it's just like something good on a
resume how hard was that test it was
really [ __ ] hard was it what's the
test for me yeah well strengthen kindig
know it was a certified strength
conditioning specialist you took a nap
during the test I took about half in the
middle to test a stupid son of a [ __ ]
nick has vital like vitamin deficiencies
for sure this dude we're at a coffee
shop chilling like we're just like
drinking coffee coffee chilling and like
I turn away for like two minutes
turn around this fools asleep at the bar
like this I
on first off this is this is the real
story you have malaria G photosynthesis
in your life micronutrients so okay two
to three like around two to three
o'clock is sleepy time for me sleepy
time sleepy time I'm up early the
morning I'm working I almost fell asleep
on the way [ __ ] over here and then
later at night I'm ready to go I'm up
and I'm up and at them all I need is
like a fifteen minute nap sometimes and
I'm good but how do you fall asleep
while drinking coffee hold on that's a
skill dude I was studying for my test
studying my ass yeah quiet it's like
cosy coffee doesn't really do it for me
at that point in time because I need a
[ __ ] take a little nap so all I do
Patrick first off didn't even realize I
fell asleep until I told him afterwards
your eyes are so small now he goes on
this [ __ ] podcast and he tells
everyone that I sleep everywhere which I
do you do they did hold on weird you're
supposed to coach people and their
[ __ ] Jiu Jitsu competition you [ __ ]
the test like see I'm studying I'm
looking this is how I used to always
cheat in school too and I would I would
be to cover my eyes and I would just
look down and he didn't [ __ ] the [ __ ]
guy next to me Patrick Reilly stand-up
comedian extraordinaire
do you even realize I was [ __ ]
sleeping until I turned to him and I was
like oh what's up man and he's like
what's up and I was like man I just fell
asleep right now he's like what the [ __ ]
really that's all she was telling you
something very important that's personal
life yeah that's how slick I was on the
open head he had no [ __ ] idea I was
asleep the whole time so joke's on you
so you look up and he just said like and
that's why I was raped
he run it back real quick I didn't hear
any of it we have a friend to UM she's
so [ __ ] funny like she when we have
sometimes when we get into like deep
conversations like so she has a 12
o'clock snooze button like right right
when hits [ __ ] in 12 a.m. she knocked
the [ __ ] out without fail
she'll be doing like [ __ ] we're all just
like having a good conversation whatever
is deep or whatever whatnot and then
she'll wake up she'll try to act like
she was awake the whole time she just
goes yeah man is exactly what isn't one
can we talk about that stuff that's when
the equilibrant breaks off and you
didn't say [ __ ] what are you doing don't
even pretend like you just knew what we
were talking about I do that we were
driving home from from Lancaster with
all of Tiff's family the backseat
Tiff's driving it's like a one o'clock
at night I'm in the passenger seat I'm
talking to TIFF and I'm like yeah like
so what's your schedule tomorrow and
then as she's talking like I'm fall
asleep and I'm talking and I wake back
up and I'm like yeah so what else you
gonna do tomorrow and then I just keep
going back and forth in and out and she
is I say yes that's the question why did
she say yes she's out of options she
spent she spent like nine years of me so
she's like just invested and [ __ ] it
he was been good for nine [ __ ] years
huh gonna be ten in January but what the
[ __ ] he is a high school right seniors
you guys met my seniors that's like a
movie right there it doesn't happen
anymore your friends like sophomore year
too oh you gotta do something special
for the 10 year what are you gonna do
for free to be a ten year anniversary oh
no man well you sound like a man [ __ ]
catch or something yeah do a vlog that'd
be cool I mean a lot to her I need you
to practice your [ __ ] block technique
right now yeah yeah so I'm gonna give
you a scenario you just woke up right in
the morning you brush your teeth and
while you're making blueberry pancakes
go all right guys so I'm working on some
blueberry pancakes today but I like a
protein mix just because you know you
get rid of the carbohydrates but at the
end of the day it's um see I'm not
really good at it already but you are
good because that's what people like
[ __ ] should I just start vlogging I was
on board dude I was with it time sailing
I [ __ ] you bail apart yeah you know
yourself I need I need a couple takes
and then I'll get it right I'm gonna
take an improv class and then maybe
something something good out of it will
come I mean for sure we're I'm talking a
lot of [ __ ] but tomorrow I'm starting a
vlog Channel watch okay well I gotta
start doing this [ __ ] yeah let's let's
all have our own blogs and then we'll
cross-promote
while you have your own vlog like I'll
vlog my life into your vlog life yeah a
session blog I'll be really cool yeah
if yeah I'll just start a vlog about
like my job and fitness and whatever the
[ __ ] not gonna start a vlog you didn't
know
I'm can't even post pictures on your
Instagram do I have a post ready to go
today and it's really kissable has
wasted my time
amen let me help you with your personal
business this is what you're gonna do
and this is what he does he writes it
all down then he puts gasoline on his
stupid son of a [ __ ] I'm like oh I have
to post videos and pictures of myself
don't want to do that he used to work
with this old white dude that looked
like a bird he look like a little parrot
they met in in a coffee shop remember
that old white guy that was like all
about [ __ ] yo who the [ __ ] is this yeah
yes he was talking [ __ ] dude and he was
talking about like SEO marketing and all
that stuff and I don't know he met him
in a coffee shop I'm pretty sure you
wanted to [ __ ] you yeah he had that but
he did but you know the point was it
good no no it was terrible my SEO
marketing SEO suck yeah that's up and I
couldn't hear that down you really got a
diversify you gotta use Bing you gotta
use Yellow Pages you got to use the FBI
to use Google that's what he was saying
Google business yeah Bing damn I ever
heard somebody who's being in ages
where's the other one [ __ ] Ask Jeeves
as johast a commission it's not up
anymore I don't know that's a good
question so what were you talking about
what the vlog views didn't know [ __ ]
with family I know is that they're
[ __ ] rich and balling out of their
mind
what are you I guarantee because they
she got caught cheating or whatever he
got caught cheating it's gonna be even
juicier vlogs everyone is gonna want to
tune in yeah now it's good good now it's
like cheating the Kardashian stuff right
it's like I was I wasn't watching this
or anything but apparently Tristan
Thompson cheated on one of the
Kardashians which which Kardashian is he
with
the taller one what's the one that looks
like a completely different person after
her 17 surgeries to her face all of them
okay but still very similar didn't
Caitlyn Jenner get woman of the year or
something like yeah that shit's tight
dude women must been really somebody she
hit somebody at her car Caitlyn Jenner
did yeah and then she turned and then
she got the surgery and then nothing
really happened after because they could
have find the guy that did he was an
Olympic gold medalist ya know but
everybody was saying because that whole
situation I was watching the episode
with my lady last night because she
watches the Kardashian show and in my
head I'm like dude they're making so
much money just often obviously maybe
whether it was planned or not I don't I
don't know if it is or whatever well
that's when people get super mad about
they she did this whole [ __ ] where she
has this new makeup line called kimono
right and I think she was trying Trull
appropriation she's trying to copyright
the word kimono or Assumption or branded
that is hers but she's clearly not
stupid you know she did that just so he
created a bunch of like fervor so people
could talk about it and you know that's
how she's been doing her whole business
model her whole life right and so people
were [ __ ] upset - like how [ __ ] you
know a lot of you know Asian people came
out the world work and they're just you
know what how dare you [ __ ] like you
know people like come on she's not dumb
you know she's doing this on purpose
right she clearly knows that kimono is a
Japanese thing right right and so you
know not be a trending topic as people
ice-crazy know people fall into it so
easily you know it's like it's so
obvious like they're just trying to
create a [ __ ] buzz it's crazy if they
give a [ __ ] about this high school as
[ __ ] in the first place like I don't
I got bills and [ __ ] like I don't care
if that cheated on her and [ __ ] you
should because it's really important it
was very hurtful or okay but yeah like
you you watch it and then
your head that was like the season
finale of course it was the season
finale it was set up it was hooked up
all the way until the 16th episode sure
enough
does he find out well really TV's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] yeah and oh the NBA
player that's on the road [ __ ] 200
days out of the year is banging other
chicks no way since when it's so
interesting because I think when people
don't see reality TV like nobody'd
realize that reality TV is in reality TV
right they have producers they have
writers they chop it up and they make it
look a certain way and they always like
[ __ ] people up with it I talked about
this on the last podcast too like I I
did this thing where I talked about a
comedian who I don't think is that funny
right but I wanted to preface it with
some nice [ __ ] because I don't want to
talk about other people's comedy when
I'm not even doing stand-up myself right
now so Who am I to say but I could say
it as a person who likes comedy right as
just as a fan and so I simply just
stated that I watch Brendan Schaub
special and that I think it's funny but
what it came out was just me trashing
him like you know about trashy thing
right yeah come on
well I but you know I think with the way
it got chopped up it made it sound like
I was somebody that was critiquing his
comedy and it wasn't the case I just
thought it was early for him to do a
huge special cuz he just started yeah
yeah exactly and then he got gassed up
by Joe Rogan and you know he does the
thing with Theo von so I think him for
myself mentally I expect him to be on
the same level as them right yeah and so
when I saw his special I was like you
just weren't a prat you were expecting a
lot more wow so what the [ __ ] is this
yeah did you watch it I did not watch it
Showtime no it's a matter with you man
we're sponsored by Showtime well not but
David is we're not I heard him on that
jor-el his podcast and he makes me
giggle I'm like oh [ __ ] he's gonna be
pretty dope like this he did one on this
isn't this is not happening yeah that
was I kind of like that I was if that
was funny that was pretty it was the
same story but it's a story right you
can tell like even in that one like that
he's still new like there was some good
moments but like you could tell like
because he is it's like it's only been
three
takes a long time to be like [ __ ]
Boober level comfortable on stage you
know so but the the story was
interesting because it was about a UFC
fight that he lost and there was funny
moments where I legitimately and it's a
good story because it's like there's a
good crossover there you know but like
an hour an hour of material that's a
whole different that's a game I just
felt like he got I don't want to say
like set up to fail a little story on
this on the Showtime special I just saw
the first few minutes and I just
couldn't get through it because like the
I felt like his joke sort of the wait I
don't know what he's it seems like he's
just talking to people that he already
knows those like I'm not in on the joke
mmm you know what I mean or like a lot
of this like I saw a small clip of him
doing stand-up about the whole Michael
Jackson thing and it wasn't even jokes
it's just regular conversation and I'm
like this is not like anybody could have
done what you just did right there like
that's just normal talk it's also
probably because his podcast their
podcast is really big I'm assuming right
so now everybody that wants to go see
him are naturally just fans yeah so he's
pretty much done like maybe an echo
chamber right where he can almost I do
no wrong to certain point I guarantee
you watch him just like maybe like in
the next like 2 or 3 years nobody's just
gonna be [ __ ] funny ya know you just
around great comics like it's just gonna
it's bound it's gonna get better yeah
yeah I didn't watch it so I need eyes
shall watch it do you guys like Amy
Schumer are you a fan of her stuff I saw
her I saw her latest special and I
didn't like it so I was you know what
the thing is like I'm always trying to
figure out this it goes well somebody
likes them there's a reason why they
sell out [ __ ] stadiums somebody
[ __ ] likes them right but I just
don't know anybody in my crowd that
likes these people so I'm trying to
figure out who their demographic is
right and there was this conversation I
had to where we were talking about mmm
you know what I'm gonna up-and-coming
comic comes up and they ask other people
they go okay well how do I be funny or
what's funny to people it's kind of hard
to say now because now I'm finding out
it's whatever you find funny somebody
else might not find money yeah it's like
music in a sense like everyone has their
taste yeah so like Who am I to say
what's funny or not there's a lot of
[ __ ] that's I don't find funny at all
but it's doing really [ __ ] well right
so maybe more comedians that you don't
think is really funny that oh I never
like I never thought Dane Cook was that
funny I thought
he had bits here in there that was
pretty funny I still think he was funny
when I was linked to seventh grade I
didn't think
Dane Cook was funny because as a [ __ ]
whatever like a 17 year old or 16 year
old who just started stand-up I could
finish his jokes I was like damn see
that's that's the other thing too is
like I feel a lot of people that they're
really popular
they don't really necessarily appeal to
like comedian fit like fans of comedy
mmm like when I was growing up I would
listen to stand up all that time like I
was always listening they're like like
Margaret Cho like any pretty much
anybody like Dave Chappelle bill burr
yeah Louie CK you know and like I said
listen to Patton Oswalt a lot I don't
know why but I would listen to him like
just like anything maybe
anyway distant like he's funny just like
at the time I was a little bit like in
high school I was I gotta get any of his
jokes but I would listen to it uh-huh
like I would listen to a lot of
different comedy but like sometimes when
you hear certain comedians like you say
Dane Cook you've kind of like heard it
all but you know where they're going
with it ya know like like say Amy
Schumer I could probably watch maybe
you're set and then kind of like get an
idea of where she's going with it but
then you listen you watch guys like Bill
burr like the greats and even like louis
c.k you don't really know where they're
going with their bits and they take it
to a whole new different perspective
that you'd even think about it but
you're like [ __ ] that makes sense like
Dave Chappelle it's like their game
changers and then when you watch that
you kind of like everyone else is yeah
it's like and I and I think like when I
watch them too I watch it with a
different eye because they're already on
the big stage so I'm not looking at them
as a developing comic that's going to
get better right this is this is who you
are at this point mm-hmm so that's
that's why for me like if I see somebody
who did comedy for the lift even five
six years and they you know they haven't
hit the big stage I'm like oh I could
see there's got being hella funny in the
future right just it's just just working
their [ __ ] out but when I see somebody
who has like six or seven specials and
that's all they got and I'm like oh then
to me to me this person is not funny to
me
yeah right right and then and that's
fine like it like I said everyone has
its a cup of tea you know I think the
key for me though is even if it's like
even if it's not my cup of tea
as long as they're being honest I'm like
okay cool like it's really just them it
just doesn't vibe for me but they're
being real like that's their thing yeah
then I get it I'm like okay like to some
people they can relate to that like you
said like the billboards the Louie CK's
like that's what separates them is that
their level of authenticity is there
yeah and I mean they're not it's not cuz
it's scary to go up there it's scared to
go up there in the beginning at all all
right sure and then you go through
phases where like you're like I just
want to make people laugh and not die up
there and then you go like go like some
pandro you do some pandering low-hanging
fruit type [ __ ] to just do that but
eventually like you see dudes kind of
like shed layers and just be like [ __ ]
everybody I was gonna say well I want to
say and that's when you're like damn
this [ __ ] is good because like they
don't care anymore and a lot of things
they say a lot of people think they just
don't want to say and they [ __ ] you and
those are the comedian's that I really
[ __ ] really like me to his is what
they say [ __ ] in my head I'm always been
thinking like Tom Segura hit one of his
special his first special I think why
everyone loved it was cuz he had a
couple bits where he was saying things
like that and you're thinking the back
your head and he would say some of the
awful [ __ ] obviously trying to be really
funny and it was just great like you're
able to kind of vibe with it you know
but like you said with a pandering [ __ ]
especially now after all the comedy that
like you know you're used to watching
you're seeing as soon as you see someone
like kind of being fake onstage yeah
you're like oh dude you know it's a rap
but so yeah like they're trying to get
the crowd on their side which I get and
it's like yeah for sure
you're kind of like its why wouldn't you
try to do that exactly that's what it is
like the whole point is for you to be I
mean yeah it's not like you're up there
like you there's there's different
styles and whatnot like it's I'm not
saying this is the only way but like one
of the things is like to be authentic
like yeah at least in your perspective
or whatever they're doing
so yeah when when someone starts
pandering or like you can really tell
they're in their act there's just a
disconnect like there's like I'm not
invested I don't care about what this
guy is really talking about with me I
mean for me - I think cuz I'm an agent
America and I see an agent stand-up
comic go and they used the same Asian
bit or joke like yeah every [ __ ]
thing it kills me dude because I know
for a fact when I see that stuff it's
just
it's the low-hanging fruit right yeah
which is cool you could open up with
that [ __ ] get them warm them up a little
bit but when I see their whole act just
go into this whole thing there was this
one Asian comic too she was a female
comic and I saw a clip of her and it was
just her just talking about Asian guys
having small dicks for like [ __ ]
don't like it already no not okay like
ten minutes and I'm like move on you
know but then you know the only people
that were laughing we're like [ __ ]
all all the white guys all the white
guys and white girls and I'm like so who
is this joke - is she she looked at the
crowd she goes I'm just gonna take a
nail for my culture and then [ __ ]
just talk about Asian guys and small
dicks and they're like there wasn't
anything which is fine I think the joke
is fine yeah but tell me something I
don't know
right so like make it funny like do
something with it yeah right make it
sound rigid again yeah and it's just
like oh god dude like what the [ __ ] we
got too many of those comics dude and it
makes me so sad because that's the easy
stuff right anyone like I feel like a
lot of people a lot of comedians how
long however long they've been doing
that they could go onstage and if they
get momentum with a bit like that that's
very low hanging fruit they could make
it they could do that all day you know
and it's like nobody wants to see that
like that right but it but eventually
they're the ones that like I said they
stay at that level for sure the dudes
that really push it or like say what
they really want yes like progress
did you watch Anthony Jeselnik specials
I did not - it okay well I usually like
I don't watch it either I thought you
guys did for some reason I don't know
why'd you bring it up you [ __ ] you
know that was jo koy specialist oh yeah
I liked it I liked I liked it sometimes
for me like because he does a lot of
like Filipino mom jokes yeah after a
while I kind of stop connecting - it is
so nice but his last one was better
mhm I so it's like and I think all of us
of his funny but it's just after a while
like I got I found it hard to connect
with his stuff because he kept talking
about his mom and his Filipino
upbringing and I couldn't relate to it
mm-hmm
so I just kind of just didn't get a lot
of the stuff but his last one was pretty
funny hmm
it was a little more broad yeah you know
like Joe Rogan's last special was
probably one of my favorites yeah she
was [ __ ] [ __ ] I usually add cuz he
was he did something kind of different
like he was a little goofy he wasn't
being like the same ol like Joe
that you're kind of used to seeing out
of all his other specials but this one
was [ __ ] hilarious dude oh did you
watch it yeah his last one I think this
is the best one yeah there's the best
one he's ever done and I was like in the
one before that I was like oh yeah this
is funny but it kind of sounds like
sometimes it sounds like he's talking on
the podcast right but the last one he
did was [ __ ] amazing I thought it was
hilarious yeah I haven't laughed that
hard in a really long time when I watch
his special but you know have you guys
seen Anthony Jeselnik special
abso-fucking-lutely night I like his
style economy that's why cuz he says
like really kind of crazy [ __ ] uck
hasn't he's not gonna come out with he
will though
he was but he tried to do a couple of
sets and some people got really mad or
something right I was like oh [ __ ] maybe
he well they taped them one right so he
was doing kind of a workout set and then
they released someone recorded it and
released it on YouTube and I listened to
and it was actually pretty good I
thought I was one of I mean it's rough
material but it was funny and then he
just performed I think that's skank fest
like they do like some like to kill Tony
guys and all that yeah they do that so
his whole thing was what he he what did
he do he masturbated in front of a girl
or something so apparently he there were
like at a Comedy Festival and they were
like he was there was a couple other
girl comics and they were like flirting
or hanging out the weekend or whatever
and then he invited him up to the hotel
they're hanging out and then he goes hey
do you guys mind if I drink off in front
of you and I guess now there's a
discrepancy whether they said no or not
but in the article it said that they
said no and then he was like alright and
then he just pulled his dick out started
jerking off and then they started
laughing
it says they started laughing and then
they but that they felt uncomfortable
and then they got up when he came he
came on his chest and they left and when
he was laying in the article it says
that he asked him what he was anyway
which one of you is Rebecca which was
after he came to her senses
damn this shot is good all the way to
his chest
no dude why would they what if he was
standing in a shot himself in the chest
cool yeah maybe I don't know I don't
know if he was standing I think he was
laying down
I would imagine but so that was the that
was the thing and so but but it was like
what the whole Harvey Weinstein thing
and they were saying that like they
respected him so he used like their
admiration in some way but then there's
people like Sarah Silverman that said
that he would like ask her to jerk off
in front of her all the time and she
would say yeah and then he would he
would do it sometimes she'd laugh and
another time she'd be like no and
wouldn't so mm oh so that's where I I
guess I okay I'm kind of remembering
there's no I guess that's where people
feel the gray areas because he asked for
consent and they said yes and then now
it's coming out that me might have said
no and so that's I guess that could have
been the part where some people feel
like if you said yes then what's the
problem or is it more like because if
his presence is so big they couldn't say
no either way right so so that then what
they try to say was that his presence
and because they admired him and like he
could offer them opportunities that's
like the power angle right that it's a
man using power so he they respected him
and like a they felt maybe if they
rejected him that he wouldn't give him
opportunities and like that's they're
saying that that dynamic is just [ __ ]
up because he's kind of he's not their
boss but he's in this position where he
could he has connections you know so
that that's where he got lumped in with
like the Weinstein thing where Weinstein
was just actually using his position by
other [ __ ] without their phone yeah
dude who's this like yo Luis you kick in
with the helos Amy you might hijack off
go ahead worldstar worldstar who's the
least famous person you would let Jack
off in front of you Nick the ear dude
that's rude seventy we continue to
northern that amber six who's the least
famous besides me I mean the least these
famous how about the most I would let
like a librarian laughter that they have
to they have to have a social media
following of ten K at the very least can
I record it and then use it for like
spank bank yeah
no not spank bank for [ __ ] oh yeah
that's amazing
four clouds oh yeah for sure [ __ ] around
I'll let the a sole guy I'll do that's
quite the platform the club McKennon no
they can service he's too famous they
can I in it famous
he got good dick though you got good and
what if Nick can actually came up to
your some dude just gave you a phone and
then you like answered it and he's like
meet me in the closet and this just Nick
Cannon jerking on and he's like I got
that good date no I'd be like all right
cool I'll be like oh no man
and I suspect I think if somebody
started doing that [ __ ] like seriously
if somebody came out said can i jack off
a funny I think the immediate answer
would be no serious for a moment guys I
would think about if any who it is I
think about it Barack Obama
yeah that's priceless yeah because dude
that's a great story you're a trash bag
I don't know man just to don't you ever
be a witness to any type of [ __ ]
crime I'm having an existential crisis
right now as I'm thinking like I could
literally not murder somebody and you
were a witness and the cop would be like
are you sure you go man possible okay
well guys this episode all right the
genius brain podcast shout-out to the
ACE family and oh yeah shout-out today
you know I I hope that you make it
through for the sake of your kids but
[ __ ] that girl maybe we're here maybe we
could do like a vlog collaboration with
all of us yeah bad on you for cheating
but [ __ ] that girl for snitching do you
ain't no [ __ ] snitch what if she
wasn't what if he wasn't though that'd
be very frustrating he probably was for
sure thousand yeah for sure he did he
came all in her face yeah I'm the
percent hardcore yeah this testing [ __ ]
you'd only do that with like people that
you
we know that well yeah but that girl as
pastor you know stupid
yes slang but he was too for slaying
[ __ ]
slang case with ABS smacking da I should
get an end Jamie yeah yeah I'll be so
mad if somebody told me to sign an NDA
and there were nobody
how [ __ ] bit like if I told somebody
inside at NDA they would be really mad
NDA they're like you are nobody sir
you're like I'm trying to keep this a
secret I'm gonna tell you don't worry
I'll [ __ ] absolutely well guys you
could guys you could you could guys okay
welcome to pocket today we are going to
learn about Nick the ear and is one con
ello sometimes make me scary sometime
make me hungry yeah but you guys can
catch us on iTunes if you see us on
iTunes make sure you give us that five
star you could see us all the way across
from Spotify cast box Pat where can they
find ya on Instagram just my name is
just Patrick Reilly check his Instagram
out for the next time he performs very
funny comic check him out hilarious make
him popular so he could pay for my [ __ ]
where they can find you guys you could
find me at Nick the ear on YouTube
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your YouTube
and then Instagram or whatever just
check his Instagram and his website [ __ ]
the YouTube hit me up guys let me know
what kind of content you want to see on
my channel subscribe to his channel he's
never uploading ever I uploaded like
last week I got the spinning backfist
video I don't want to see wire coming
for you guys this week stay tuned son of
a [ __ ]
alright guys we'll see you next time
please